have you ever asked yourself where the
boundaries of our universe are
how far exactly it extends my guess is
you would not have come up with a
satisfactory answer
even if you spent hours on end trying to
figure it out
no wonder as the universe is like the
horizon you take one step forward
and it glides two steps further away
from you
in spite of this disappointing fact a
great number of really fascinating
discoveries and space exploration have
been made in science
and now i'll tell you about a few of
them we will set out on a journey to the
boundaries of our milky way
reach the limits of the observable
universe take a look at a pulsar
the trappist-1 system a magnetar the
most massive black hole
and we'll speculate about why we still
haven't come across
any intelligent life forms in our
pursuit of exploring the universe
an exciting journey is up ahead let's
get started
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
galaxy is a common name for a system of
stars
clusters interstellar gas dust
dark matter and planets which all are
bound together by one gravitational
energy
all objects in a galaxy are in motion
with respect to the general center of
its mass
as a rule these are really remote
astronomical objects
with the distances to them measured in
megaparsecs
we can make out only several of them
with the naked eye
the andromeda galaxy seen in the
northern hemisphere
the large and small magellanic clouds
seen in the southern hemisphere
and the m33 galaxy in the triangulum
constellation
seen from the northern hemisphere as
well
the exact number of galaxies in the
observable part of the universe
isn't known but their number may well
reach
2 trillion only in the 20th century was
it made possible to observe
some of them by the early 1990s
not more than 30 galaxies were
registered where stars were visible
and which were part of the local group
that is the cluster of galaxies
forming one large hole known as the
virgo supercluster
after the launch of the hubble telescope
in april 1990 however
the inflow of information about new
galaxies
soared dramatically today
they are subdivided into several general
classes
the first class is satellite or
companion galaxies
which are objects orbiting around a
larger galaxy due to the gravity of the
latter
the second class is spiral galaxies
which are peculiar for the central bulge
cocooned in a disk
and the third class is irregular
galaxies typically unsuited to either
the proposed categories
as a rule they are chaotic formations
with neither clear nucleus nor spiral
arms
lenticular or so galaxies elliptical
galaxies and barred spiral galaxies like
our own milky way
fall into this category too
the approximate diameter of each of them
ranges from 5 to 250 kilopas
sex or 16 to 800 000
light years just to compare the diameter
of the milky way is 30 kilopas
sex that is a hundred thousand light
years
the largest galaxy known today is called
ic1101
and it boasts a diameter of over 6
million light years
the principal problem in studying the
structure of a galaxy
is the mystery of the dark matter today
the dark matter is believed to account
for up to 90
of the overall mass of a given galaxy
alternatively another galaxy may be
completely devoid of it
but which of these objects can be
defined as the nearest to us
many would argue that it's the andromeda
galaxy that is the closest
which is located 2.52 million light
years away
however this is the closest object among
the largest spiral galaxies
as for the closest galaxy a hypothetical
canis major dwarf galaxy should be named
this astronomical object belongs to the
local group as well
the galaxy contains a comparatively high
percentage of red giant stars
and presumably a billion regular stars
it is classified as an irregular galaxy
and is officially considered our nearest
neighbor
the galaxy is located 25 000 light years
away from the solar system
and 42 000 light years from the center
of the milky way
this object was discovered in november
2003 by an international team of
astronomers
in spite of its close location to the
earth the galaxy wasn't easy to spot
because it is located beyond the plane
of the milky way
in the area with stellar gas and dust
over density
our second closest neighbor is the
sagittarius dwarf elliptical galaxy
which used to be considered the first
one as well
it is a satellite galaxy with a clearly
defined elliptical structure
with its orbit passing over the milky
way
the object contains four globular
stellar clusters
with the first of them discovered in
which led to the discovery of the galaxy
itself
its diameter makes up about 10 000
light years it is about 70 000
light years away from the earth and
fifty thousand light years
away from the core of the milky way it
is thanks to this galaxy that the milky
way may have obtained its arm structure
this conclusion is based on numerical
modeling
it was arrived at by researchers from
the university of pittsburgh
according to their version the arms of
our galaxy
may have been obtained as a result of a
collision with the sagittarius dwarf
elliptical galaxy this object
is currently in the process of merging
with the milky way
it should be noted that it has passed
through the plane of our galaxy
several times the last time took place
about 150 million years ago
which agrees with the data received by
the gaia telescope
when speaking about our nearest
neighbors one can't but mention the
large and the small magellanic clouds
two dwarf galaxies and satellites of the
milky way
the large magellanic cloud is 163
000 light years away from us
that is a distance almost one and a half
times bigger than our galaxy
the large magellanic cloud finds itself
in the area between the dorado and
mensah constellations in the southern
hemisphere
which is the reason why it is unlikely
to be seen from most of eurasia
the galaxy is approximately 10 times
smaller than the milky way
and contains approximately 30 billion
stars
the mass of the large magellanic cloud
is about 300 times as small as that of
our galaxy however
it does not prevent it from holding the
fourth place among all the local group
galaxies in terms of its mass
beaten only by the andromeda galaxy the
milky way galaxy and the triangulum
galaxy
one of the best known objects in this
galaxy is woh
g64 a star considered to be one of the
largest
known to science its radius is 1540
times that of the sun
hypothetically placed in the core of the
solar system
it would reach as far as the orbit of
saturn
with its edges the milky way and the
large magellanic cloud
are expected to collide in approximately
2.4 billion years time
its neighbor a small magellanic cloud
should also be mentioned
it is a dwarf galaxy too and is
enveloped in neutral hydrogen
the small cloud is 60 kilopas away from
us
that is approximately 195 000 light
years
it is located in the tucana
constellation and has the appearance of
a faint spot
about three degrees in size 1.5 billion
stars are thought to be found in the
small magellanic cloud
however they're not visible from most of
eurasia either
according to the data published in
september 2014
the milky way is likely to swallow up
this object as well
in four billion years time to date
the number of satellite galaxies in the
milky way equals 18
but the number of large systems closest
to us
reaches 115. this is hardly the full
list of these objects
because new dwarf systems are discovered
now from time to time not far from the
milky way
pinpointing and exploring objects like
that is a rather arduous task
however the search for nearest galaxies
remains one of the chief objectives in
astronomy today
their discovery might give us insights
into new planets
similar to the earth and might lead to
the discovery of life forms
in the nearest parts of the universe
the statement that there are boundaries
to the universe is considered per se
one of those great ideas which are able
to dramatically change our world
perception
something similar took place back in
when nicholas copernicus proved that the
earth wasn't located
in the center of the cosmos the
following breakthrough took place in the
20th century
when edwin hubble showed to the world
that galaxies moved away from each other
this prompted the idea that the universe
hasn't existed eternally
and was formed as a result of a certain
event
the big bang today we are certain that
the dimensions of the world we live in
are much larger than we are capable of
imagining
the search for the answer to the
question about its boundaries
is going to lead to yet another
scientific breakthrough
at the moment scientists are able to
talk only of the boundaries
within which the objects are visible
this area is also called the observable
universe
that is its part which is the absolute
past in relation to the observer the
cosmic horizon
is the boundary of the observable
universe the objects on the horizon
become
infinitely red-shifted that is they
constantly move
further away the number of galaxies
within the observable universe is
estimated at upwards of 500 billion
with this number increasing on a regular
basis
as the research equipment becomes more
advanced
but how big is the observable area of
the universe
today the distance to the remotest
observable objects
equals approximately 14 billion parsecs
in all directions thus the observable
universe
is a sphere with a diameter of about 93
billion light years
and with the center inside the solar
system
that is it is centered on the observer
the area equals 350 quin vigentillion
cubic meters
it should be mentioned that the light
emitted by the further most observable
objects
has been traveling for 13.8 billion
light years
before reaching us however the distance
to those objects has significantly grown
due to the never ceasing expansion of
the universe
this process is the result of there
being matter and energy in space
filling space-time
while there is matter in space there is
gravitational force
therefore the universe either shrinks
affected by gravity
or expands affected by dark matter
it is also worth noting that there isn't
a single center for the universe's
expansion
just like there isn't a space for the
universe to expand into
beyond its boundaries this process takes
place with the matter in space
at any point everywhere and at all times
we do not physically perceive this as
the force holding our atoms and
molecules together
does not allow us to burst under the
influence of the space
expansion this may be compared to a
baking loaf of bread
with the raisins for galaxies and
similar formations
and the dough for the space matter
according to estimates
the distance to the furthermost
observable objects today
equals approximately 14 giga parsecs
or 46 billion light years
the furthermost stellar system with
respect to the earth is a galaxy dubbed
gnz11 its light has been traveling to us
for about 13.4 billion years
meaning that this object was formed less
than 400 million years
after the big bang however
due to the constant expansion of the
universe today's distance to gnz11 is
approximately
32 billion light years
one may argue that the speed with which
it recedes exceeds the speed of
light but it does not clash with a
special theory of relativity
as it isn't the matter that is receding
but the space
between the two objects is growing
larger
this object is supposedly one of the
very first galaxies
and is likely to be the closest stellar
cluster
to the edge of the observable universe
if men were able to freely travel from
one world to another
it is in that galaxy that we might find
out about the genesis of our world
in more detail what we call the meta
galaxy
is likely to have started to expand
immediately on its birth
in theory the boundaries of the meta
galaxy may well reach the cosmic
singularity
that is it may show us what the world
had been like before the big bang
but in practice it is relic radiation
that is the limit to the observable
it is this radiation that is emitted by
the furthermost object in the universe
to have been observed in contemporary
science
this radiation poses something like a
barrier for our vision
it came about approximately 380
000 years after the big bang that is at
the time when the universe cooled off
sufficiently for atoms to emerge
in plain english it is similar to an
image of space in its childhood
where it is depicted before the
formation of the first stars
it is likely that the universe stretches
infinitely beyond this barrier
and it is there that its hypothetical
boundaries are to be found
the objects beyond this barrier are
referred to in a number of ways
multiverse objects parallel universe
objects to name the two
science today is incapable of defining
these bodies with any detail
however assuming that the universe
carries on expanding
we may conclude that the objects we're
able to observe
now are sooner or later going to
disappear from our field of vision
if the accelerating expansion of the
universe continues indefinitely
the galaxies beyond our supercluster are
sooner or later going to recede beyond
the horizon as a result
thus becoming invisible to us any form
of communication beyond the boundaries
of the observable universe will be
rendered impossible
and any contact between the objects will
be lost
the earth the solar system the milky way
and our supercluster
will be mutually observable whereas the
rest of the universe will recede in the
distance
there may be hypothetical worlds beyond
the regions observable to us
they originate as a result of phase
transitions of physical vacuum
alternatively there may be objects
forming out of irregularities of relic
radiation
located closest to the particle horizon
the question of multiverse objects
remains a bone of contention among
scientists
prompting an overwhelming number of
pseudo-scientific guesses
be it as it may most researchers see eye
to eye
as to the infinity of our universe
although they interpret it in different
ways
some of them claim our world to be
multi-dimensional
which makes our three-dimensional
universe merely one of its
layers others are inclined to believe in
the theory of a multi-universe
with us as a minuscule fraction of an
infinite multitude
whereas there may be a portal to other
worlds beyond the observable area of the
universe
some space theories involve the
existence of the so-called event horizon
according to this concept we're never
going to be able to look beyond the
event horizon
because the speed at which photons
travel away from us
will be higher than the speed with which
the observable universe
expands according to this theory
all the galaxies surrounding us are
bound to recede beyond the event horizon
it will look like time stopped in them
we will observe them
infinitely receding beyond the
observable boundaries
but never quite disappearing from view
be it as it may contemporary science
cannot provide a definite answer to this
question
although the situation may change
overnight once we have developed
more advanced observation equipment the
universe might turn out to be a sort of
sphere
and traveling over it might remind one
of traveling on the spherical surface
of our earth considering the scale it
reaches however
this prospect appears impossible
in order to reach the edge of the
observable universe it would take man 46
billion years even if we travel
at the speed of light by the time we
reached
this designated point it would have
moved the same distance away
and a similar journey would have to be
embarked upon
it is likely that there aren't any large
objects beyond the observable universe
and on peering there we would see just a
homogeneous cloud of helium
hydrogen and a few other elements
however we might probably never be able
to discover the origins of our world
and might forever remain in the position
of someone
chasing the horizon
july 1967 a series of passes was
detected with the help of a radio
telescope at cambridge university
by a postgraduate jocelyn bell they
emanated from a pulsar
as yet unknown at the time and the
results of the observations were kept
secret for several months
the object was initially designated lgm1
which stood for little green men the
name was given following the assumption
that these perfectly regular pulses
were not a natural phenomenon but
signals of artificial origin
supposedly transmitted by an alien
civilization
besides the team of scientists under
jocelyn bell discovered three other
sources of similar signals
the phenomenon took seven years to
investigate and the thesis advisor of
jocelyn bell's team
was later awarded the nobel prize for
studying this celestial body
which was subsequently dubbed bsr b1919
21 this pulsar was the first
registered phenomenon of its kind its
source was to be discovered several
years later in the constellation
vulpecula
or little fox 2 283 light years from the
earth
information about psr b1919 plus 21 was
made public in february 1968
and by 1969 the number of detected
pulses of this kind
reached 27 and the term pulsar was
coined as the official name for these
objects
the first discovered source of this
signal was the object
dubbed double po943 it was spotted by
soviet astronomers in the leo
constellation
one of the most widespread assumptions
at the time regarding this discovery
was that all pulsars were in fact
ultra-powerful radio beacons of
extraterrestrial civilizations and the
pulsating signals remind one of a
lighthouse twinkling in the night
however it wasn't long before
astronomers agreed that the regular
signals were most likely emanated by
neutron stars
today it is posited that these impulses
originate as a result of a neutron stars
spinning
and are in fact thin beams of radio
waves
they are detected by the observer at
precise regular intervals
which accounts for the past appearance
of this emission
approximately 1 790 pulsars had been
discovered by 2008
all of them were powerful sources of
impulse radio emissions in space
as for the pulsars closest to us they
are located several dozen light years
away from the sun
after pulsars were first detected other
pulsating sources of similar nature were
registered by astronomers
they were described as powerful flares
of regular intermittent x-ray emissions
thus they got their name x-ray pulsars
x-ray pulsars are also highly magnetized
neutron stars but unlike
radio pulsars which use their own
rotational energy
x-ray pulsars are powered by accretion
disks an accretion disk
is formed from material captured from
the companion star with the latter
eventually becoming a white dwarf with
all of its resources
depleted thus the mass and spin rate of
x-ray pulsars gradually build up during
the course of their revolution
as for radio pulsars they on the
contrary slow down as time goes by for
example
the average radio pulsar completes one
rotation within the period from several
seconds to several tenths of a second
with x-ray pulsars completing hundreds
of rotations within the same time period
one of celestial bodies of this kind was
discovered quite recently
and it is located rather close to our
system
the object was dubbed j1023 plus double
o
38 and its source caught astronomers eye
as recently as at the beginning of the
21st century however its passes reached
the earth
only in 2017. this was the first ever
millisecond optical pulsar to be
discovered
in essence such celestial bodies are
neutron stars as well
with a rotation period ranging from 1 to
10 milliseconds
the spin rate of these pulsars is
several times that of regular pulsars
they form part of binary systems and
their spin rate
increases to incredible speeds is the
direct result of the pulsar pulling
material from the gaseous disc produced
by its companion star of a smaller mass
it should be noted that when a neutron
star is in its active accretion phase
we see it as a source of x-rays when the
rate at which it pulls the material
drops
bright pulsed radiation can be seen in
the radio and gamma spectra
to date a few more pulsars of this
transitional kind are known to science
which fluctuate
between the x-ray and radio spectra in a
similar manner
however it was the first ever
transitional optical pulsar with a spin
rate of this intensity
discovered by scientists the rotation
period of j 1023 plus double o 38
is 1.69 milliseconds which is 0.00169 of
a second
the object itself is four and a half
thousand light years
away from us the mass of its companion
star is point to
that of the sun it takes the pulsar 4.45
hours to orbit its companion star once
to date the properties of j-1023 plus
double o
38 have not been investigated in detail
although it is likely to be a not very
massive neutron star
although the object was initially
considered to be a radio pulsar
in 2013 scientists noticed that its
impulses regularly subsided
and it was known to flare up in the
x-ray spectrum
according to scientists this phenomenon
may be accounted for by the fact
that the pulsar was at the moment in
between the phases which looks like the
following
radio emissions occur when material from
the companion star is pulled to the
pulsar
but star wind does not allow material to
form an accretion disk
that is why the gas cannot heat up much
and looks brighter in the radio spectrum
in the second phase the stream of
material from the companion of j1023
plus double o 38 gets stronger
and forms an accretion disk around the
pulsar the disc is in fact the source of
observable
x-ray emissions it wasn't long before
millisecond pulsating was detected in
the optical band of j1023 plus w38
as testified by earlier observations
carried out with the help of the swift
x-ray telescope
the neutron star was surrounded by an
accretion disk at the time
according to those in charge of the
studies the pulsar may have started to
flare up on the optical band due to
electrons in its magnetosphere when
these electrons speed was close to the
speed of light
in the future astrophysicists plan to
conduct additional observations
to study processes taking place within
this binary system
and now to the object of the kind
located furthest away from us that is
known to science
it is ngc 5907x1
a celestial body which is also the
brightest of all pulsars discovered by
now spotted in 2017
this pulsar is an ultra bright x-ray
source
shockingly it releases as much energy in
one rotation period
as the sun produces in three and a half
years
earlier astrophysicists believed these
ultra bright
x-ray sources to be black holes however
after the discovery of ngc 5907x1
it became known that they may turn out
to be pulsars too
the object is located approximately 50
million light years away from our sun
as for its spin rate it is variable for
example
in 2003 the rotation period of the
pulsar was 1.43 seconds
whereas in 2014 it dropped to 1.13
seconds
just to compare if our earth were to be
able to change its rotation speed in the
same manner
a day on our planet would last just 19
hours
modern astrophysical models cannot
account for the intense luminosity of
ngc 5907x1
although scientists believe it to have
something to do with a powerful
multipolar magnetic field
that may be concealed within the pulsar
it will take even more complex studies
to find out the reason for the emission
of such staggering amounts of energy
just a few decades ago the phenomenon of
a pulsar was beyond any explanation
and today science is able to
differentiate between this phenomenon
and any other in space our civilization
strides forward which leads us to
believe that even this century may
reveal a number of other phenomena
unheard of in the past the universe is
like a giant canvas
with quite a few blank areas as our
knowledge about space
builds up the pattern on the canvas gets
altered too
with regularly applied changes it may
soon turn into a fully fledged map of
our enormous universe
explored by man
this object is a single star with a
planetary system
and there are at least three celestial
bodies within the habitable zone
now let's look at it in more detail the
distance between trappist-1 and
our sun is 39 and a half light years
the object was discovered in the period
from 2016 to 2017.
this single star is a red dwarf of
spectral type
m8v as for its dimensions
it is only 12.1 percent of our sun's
radius
just to compare it isn't in fact much
larger than jupiter
the mass of trappist-1 is 27 000 times
that of our earth
but at the same time is 0.08 the mass of
our sun
with the average temperature reaching
2500 kelvins
its luminosity is 1900 times weaker in
comparison with that of the main star of
our system
the orbital period of trappist-1 is 3.3
days
as for its age it is seven and a half
billion years
which makes it almost three billion
years older than the sun
the distance between this star and us is
diminishing
as it is slowly but surely drifting
towards our system
this object aroused interest largely
following the discovery of its planetary
system back in 2016
whose three components were spotted by
transit method with the help of an
automated 0.6 meter telescope in the
european southern observatory or the eso
in chile the planets were initially
dubbed trappist-1b
trappist-1c and trappist-1d
however further investigations revealed
that the presumed location of
trappist-1d
was described incorrectly following that
four more earth-like
objects were discovered by astronomers
with the help of the spitzer space
telescope
these were dubbed trappist a f g
and h thus the total number of planets
in the system reached
seven and on the 13th of april 2016
the parameters of these celestial
objects were defined in more detail
all the seven exoplanets are identical
to our earth in terms of their
dimensions
with their radii ranging from 0.71
to 1.13 that of our planet planets b
and c orbit their parent star in the
periods of 1.51
and 2.42 days respectively
initially according to astrophysicists
both of these planets were comparable to
venus
in all but exceptionally high
temperatures
however after their mass and density had
been measured
it was trappist-1 that could be called
venus's analog
trappist-1b the second closest planet to
its star
is likely to contain a large amount of
water and other volatile elements
the new data enabled scientists to find
out more about the other
discovered planets too
it takes trappist-1d 4.05 days to orbit
its star
its radius is 0.77 that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 e is
6.1 days
its radius is 0.92 that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 f may
last
up to 9.2 earth days its radius is 1.04
that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 g is
12.3 days
and its radius is 1.13 that of the earth
last but not least trappist-1 h is the
seventh object
and is the furthest from its star with a
rotation period of 18 days
and a radius of 0.7 that of our planet
it should be mentioned that the initial
estimates of the object's masses
were likely to be rather conservative
due to the analysis of the density of
the first six planets
it was later ascertained that they
contain a big amount of water and other
volatile elements
which makes them considerably lighter
than thought previously
as for the furthest of them e f g and
h for all we know they may consist
entirely of water
only trappist-1c boasts a mass bigger
than initially estimated
which may be indicative of over 50
percent of iron in its composition
of the seven planets known to be located
in the trappist-1 system
three of them find themselves within the
habitable zone
namely d e and f speaking about the rest
of them
following the estimates of its density
planet b is thought to contain either a
small nucleus
or else a considerable amount of
volatile elements
due to high temperatures of 127 and 69
degrees celsius above zero
on the surfaces of planets b and c
respectively
water is not likely to remain in its
liquid state there
and is bound to float about as vapor as
for planets g and h
they're too remote from their central
star to be potentially habitable
however according to models suggested at
cornell university
the habitable zone of trappist-1 may
well be wider
and allowing for volcanic hydrogen
potentially acting as a greenhouse gas
there may be four planets within the
habitable zone
rather than three the density of
trappist-1 f
is rather low too and so it may well
turn out to be an all-ocean planet
here are the temperatures for all the
planets in the system the steady-state
temperatures are given without including
incident light dispersion
and greenhouse effects just to compare
the steady-state temperature on our
planet in the same conditions
would measure four degrees above zero
and on mars
47 degrees below zero
in november 2017 it was posited that the
activity of this star didn't allow its
planets to form and maintain their own
atmosphere
it is accounted for by the fact that
trappist-1 goes through periods of
active flares
which may negatively affect the nearby
celestial bodies
and thus render them uninhabitable for
living organisms as we know them
interestingly the planets are located
much closer to each other in comparison
to our systems planets
the planet mercury which is the closest
one to the sun
is located 0.39 astronomical units from
it
while the distance between trappist 1b
and its parent star is just 0.01
astronomical units
as trappist-1 is a rather dim star it is
no easy matter to explore it
red dwarfs like that are quite
widespread across the universe
accounting for most of the galaxy's
stellar matter
plasma ejections on these stars are a
rare occasion
although astronomers believe that there
may be giant cold areas and compact hot
areas with temperatures
upwards of four thousand kelvins on the
surface of trappist-1
if this conjecture proves to be true
scientists will proceed to confirm that
the system's planets are constantly
bombarded by powerful ultraviolet and
x-ray radiation which is able to destroy
their atmospheres
and render their surface completely
sterile
the reason for that lies in the fact
that none of the microorganisms known on
the earth
are able to withstand intensive
radiation emanating from flares of this
kind
including the most radiation resistant
bacteria dana caucus radiodurans
nevertheless in december 2017
atmosphere was proven to persist even in
periods of high activity of stars
which implies that planets g and h may
potentially have their own atmospheres
at the moment astrophysicists idea is to
use more up-to-date telescopes for
studying the matter
for example the james webb space
telescope whose launch is planned for
march 2021 today the trappist system
presents a great interest for the global
scientific community
and even though it is highly unlikely
that any advanced civilization will be
discovered on its planets
we cannot ignore the fact that life
forms in the universe may be extremely
diverse
and may differ from our perceptions of
life as we know it
which implies that not all intelligent
organisms are supposed to follow the
scenario of our planet
if science manages to find out more
details about this system in the nearest
decades
many conjectures and doubts we have
today about trappist-1
will most likely be cleared
mankind has come across some extremely
powerful radiation that reached us from
deep space
several times in the last 50 years
but as often as the case with space
discoveries the source was slow in being
detected by astrophysicists
1979 three u.s
velar satellites monitoring nuclear
tests on the earth
detected an unusual gamma-ray flare
1992 astrophysicists assumed that there
was a celestial object out there not
known to science with a huge
electromagnetic radiation coefficient
1998 a gamma-ray flare in the
constellation aquila
a number of measuring devices registered
an unaccountable anomaly with its source
located
tens of thousands of light years away
from us
2004 all telescopes in the world were
for a short time
dazzled less than a second later
every cubic centimeter in the solar
system experienced a wave of gamma ray
radiation
the most massive burst in the entire
history of observations
and today we're closer than ever to
finally putting our finger on the nature
of this discovery
a magnetar is a neutron star with an
exceptionally powerful magnetic field of
about 10 to the power of 13 teslas
which in essence is trillions of times
that of the electromagnetic radiation
on the earth it is also one of the
rarest and really most
dangerous phenomena ever encountered by
mankind
when a supermassive star is on the point
of dying
a supernova occurs among the multiple
scenarios of what may take place after
that
only one may lead to the star becoming a
magnetar after the supernova
many of you would have heard about the
russian roulette at least once in your
lives
according to the rules only one
cartridge is put on the revolver's
cylinder
the chance of producing a shot after you
have spun the cylinder is rather small
however when it does happen the
consequences are truly mind-blowing
be it as it may scientists are still at
odds over what exactly this scenario
would look like
according to the first theory it's the
inner energy of the star and its
rotational energy that influenced the
formation of a magnetar
if a neutron star is formed at the time
of fast rotation
the inner energy of this star as well as
its rotational energy
which is of great significance in the
first several seconds
all create a powerful magnetic field
this process is known to science as a
dynamo mechanism
but there is another theory as well
after the accretion process
the magnetar may be able to receive
energy from another star
scientists have discovered a magnetar
which is on an escape trajectory from
our galaxy
most moving stars we know set off on
their trajectories
as a result of supernovae in binary
systems
this means that the accretion process
takes place between the two stars with a
common mass center
in a binary system matter from one star
gradually flows to the other in this
case
this is the source of energy for a
potential magnetar
something similar happens with a
basketball spinning around the edge of
the basket
sooner or later it is going to fall but
it's the spinning process that
predefines the direction of the fall
magnetars spin on their axis extremely
fast
with a speed varying between tens and
thousands of times per second
at the same time their dimensions are
record small
as a rule the diameter of a magnetar
reaches a measly 20 to 30 kilometers
just to compare the diameter of the moon
equals
3474 kilometers
that is about 173 times that of the
average magnetar
the mass however is a completely
different matter
a magnetar with a diameter of 15
kilometers will be significantly heavier
than our sun
despite the dimensions it is its
staggeringly powerful density of the
interior that is the reason
for its high magnetic radiation for
instance
8.1 minus 5937
is an anomalous x-ray pulsar located
9000 light years away
in the constellation karina the star the
magnetar evolved from
had the mass 30 to 40 times that of our
sun
the mata in these stars is dense to such
a point that a fountain pen cap
would weigh billions of tons and a human
would be torn to bits within a matter of
seconds after landing on the star's
surface
several years ago astronomers from nasa
managed to register a phenomenon which
came to be known as a stark wake
thanks to the fermi gamma-ray space
telescope
scientists received data about intense
x-ray bursts
their source was magnetar sgr j1550-5418
the magnetic field of this star is so
powerful
that from time to time its crust bursts
with vast amounts of energy released
through the crack
such stock wakes are the source of
post-electric current
in theory if a magnetar of this kind at
its most active
were to find itself within the
boundaries of the solar system
we wouldn't as much as notice the threat
as the ozone layer of the earth
together with all organic life forms
would be wiped off within a matter of a
few hundreds of a second
fortunately however the magnetar closest
to us
is a safe enough distance away
a magnetar is hard to approach not only
due to the gravitational properties of
its core
and energy flares at the time of a stock
wake when a magnetize in its stable
condition
its magnetic field is able to mess with
electric devices hundreds of thousands
of kilometers away
and within the radius of a thousand
kilometers any object would be reduced
to atoms
in order to systematize the difference
in their radiation
scientists decided to divide magnetars
into two varieties by using
abbreviations
rather than the full names you will see
these in any astronomical catalog
sgr soft gamma repeater
and dxp anomalous x-ray pulsar
in essence sgi and dxp are different
phases in the life of one and the same
object
according to scientists a magnetar
exists as an sgr
pulsar for the first 10 000 years
that is it's a pulsar visible in regular
light and repeatedly emitting bursts of
soft gamma rays
as time goes by it exhausts its
properties and recedes into the
invisible spectrum
when it can be seen to us only in the
x-ray range
as an axp
according to different sources today
among billions of neutron stars
the number of known potential magnetars
ranges from 30 to 150
there are about 12 of them in the milky
way the magnetize a soft gamma repeater
and if a stark wake were to take place
on its surface
it would affect us only by some slight
changes in the top layers of the
ionosphere
due to their small dimensions and
remoteness relative to the earth
magnetars cannot be observed through
regular amateur telescopes
the method of infrared or x-ray scanning
of the sky is usually employed to
observe them
nevertheless thanks to their active
magnetic field emission and radiation
these stars are much easier to detect
with the use of various instruments
this is exactly what took place several
years ago
in 2013
astronomers claimed to have discovered a
magnetar in close proximity to a
supermassive black hole right in the
middle of the milky way
the star was detected thanks to several
orbital telescopes
including the chandra x-ray space
observatory
sgr 1745-2900
is only 0.3 light years away from the
edge of the black hole
and to date it remains the only neutron
star to have been discovered
in close proximity to an object of this
scale
sgr 1745-290
has been observed by scientists ever
since its discovery
several years ago the level of its x-ray
radiation
was proclaimed to be significantly lower
than that of the stars of this category
the news prompted numerous debates
can these changes have been caused by
the black hole in the stars environs
after two years of observing sgr
1745-2908
astrophysicists came to the conclusion
that all things considered
the distance of 0.3 light years is
insufficient for any interaction in the
magnetic or gravitational field
to take place between the black hole and
the magnetar after
all the reason is likely to lurk
elsewhere
a magnetar's lifespan is quite short
just about a million years and it's
quite natural for its magnetic field to
gradually die
down throughout the star's existence
some scientists assume that these
processes may be the reason for the
change of the star's status
in this case magnetars can switch their
category flare up more frequently or
less often
deplete the stock of the matter and thus
go from the category of sgr to the
category of axp
in its autumn years a former magnetar
that managed to survive the dissipation
of its magnetic field
may even become quite a different kind
of star
namely a thermally emitting neutron star
so far just about seven objects of the
kind are known to science
for their number this group has been
dubbed the magnificent seven
and each of them may once have been one
of the most dangerous
objects of deep space but in order to
establish that
it will take us long years further
technological advancements and dedicated
people
willing to devote their lives to
searching for solutions
to the most dangerous and incredible
mysteries
of the universe
a perfect example of these eerie
celestial objects
are black holes their sheer existence
was considered impossible
until only recently when on the 10th of
april
2019 the national science foundation in
the usa
showed the world an image revealing a
black hole
in the middle of the messier 87 galaxy
this object has a mass approximately 6.6
billion times that of the sun with a
diameter of about a hundred billion
kilometers
just to compare the diameter of the
earth is only 12
742 kilometers this hole
falls into the category of supermassive
black holes
a similar object can also be found in
the center of the milky way
it is called sagittarius a and boasts
from
two to five million times the sun's mass
according to different estimates
the diameter of sagittarius a is 45
astronomical units
in other words 45 times the distance
from the earth to the
sun but is it possible to admit of the
existence of even larger black holes in
space
and which of them is the largest let's
figure it out
a black hole is a term referring to an
area in space with an
incredibly powerful gravitation in the
center
as a rule these objects are rather small
at first
and are able to expand as they actively
build up their masses
black holes are categorized according to
their masses
the heavier ones are called supermassive
black holes
at the moment scientists haven't formed
a unanimous opinion
as to how these objects come about in
space
according to the most popular theory
that of gradual expansion
when a black hole appears it has a mass
typical of a star
and later on it grows by sucking in the
surrounding matter
the amount of information accumulated by
science about these objects is rather
scarce
but even based on the current data a
supposition can easily be made about
there being at least
several such holes in the center of any
large galaxy
in the time the universe has existed a
few million
or even billion of black holes are
likely to have been formed in it by now
at least today only a small fraction of
them
is known to us the champion in terms of
its mass
is the black hole in the center of a
quasar
known as tan 618 this object was
stumbled upon in 1957
when white dwarfs were being explored
and initially caused a lot of puzzlement
on the part of the scientists
the notion of quasars was to appear only
six years later
that is why the nature of the object was
rather vague
on photographic plates taken with a 0.7
meter schmidt telescope
it was listed as number 618 and
described as decidedly violet it was
only in 1970 that radio mission from 10
618 was discovered at the institute for
radio astronomy of bologna
this emission was indicative of the fact
that it was a quasar
and moreover the most luminous quasar
known to science
at the time it is assumed that there's
an accretion disk of hot gas in tons 618
surrounding a gargantuan black hole in
the center of the galaxy
the gas must move around the disk at a
tremendous speed
reaching several thousand kilometers per
second
this object is located in the
constellation of hunting dogs or caney's
venatici
and is 10.37 billion light years away
from us
the galaxy containing tons-618 cannot be
seen from the earth due to the
luminosity of the quasar itself
which is 140 trillion times as intense
as that of the sun
the contemporary view on quasars defines
them as active nuclei of galaxies
at the first stage of their formation
the nuclei's supermassive black hole
sucks in the surrounding matter thus
forming an accretion disk
this disc is the source of luminosity of
enormous power
that is sometimes more intense than the
aggregate luminosity of all stars and
galaxies like ours the brightest quasar
which was discovered in january 2019
has the luminosity of about 600 trillion
suns and is 12.8 billion
light years away from the earth
what could be the mass of an object
finding itself in the center of a light
cannon like this
according to today's estimates the mass
of the black hole in the center of the
tan
618 quasar reaches 66 billion times the
sun's mass
which makes it the heaviest black hole
in our galaxy
known to science black holes of this
mass
are categorized in a different group and
are referred to as ultra massive black
holes
in fact the tan 618 quasar
isn't the only object in this category
within the constellation of cancer for
example which is 3.5 billion light years
away from us
the oj287 quasar is to be found
it has a black hole in the center and is
18 billion
sun's masses
in the center of the phoenix cluster
there's a rapidly expanding black hole
which at this moment is 20 billion times
the sun's mass
building up 60 sun's masses
one of the best known black hair giants
is located in the galaxy
ngc 1277 within the perseus
constellation
the object reaches 21 billion suns
masses
and its event horizon diameter equals
130 billion kilometers
which is 15 times the distance from
neptune to the sun
however at the moment this giant
practically isn't being active
speaking about size the undisputed
holder of the first
place on the list is admittedly another
well-known space object
namely the black hole in the center of
holmberg 15a
a supermassive elliptical galaxy located
in the constellation
cetus or the whale 700 million
light years away from the earth this
black hole
isn't a champion in terms of its mass
which is 40 billion times the sun's mass
its dimensions however can't but amaze
according to today's estimates the event
horizon of this black hole
could be as big as to accommodate our
sun and all of its planets
its diameter is approximately 790
astronomical units the helmberg
15a galaxy must have been formed as a
result of the collision of two smaller
galaxies
at some point in the distant past
a similar process is likely to be
expected in our system as well
when the milky way collides with the
andromeda galaxy
in four billion years time
for now astronomers plan to continue
studying the phenomenon of the black
hole and holmberg 15a
by carrying out complex and detailed
modelling
scientists are going to collate the
results of theoretical calculations with
practical observations in the future
in order to try to establish how exactly
it was possible for a tremendous black
hole
to come into being inside the two
galaxies on their collision
in comparison to the objects mentioned
above our own planet
may seem of no significance at all on
the overall space map
but it should be noted that the age of
practically all the supermassive objects
in the universe
is several times that of our earth
for millions of years these black holes
have been gaining in their masses
and expanding as the time went by
today we can observe their activeness as
the result of the development of the
entire universe it is quite feasible
that most of the ultra massive black
holes were formed as a result of smaller
holes merging
a similar process takes place when they
collide which is accompanied by the
emission of gravitational waves
these occurrences must be the biggest
contributors to the generating
gravitational waves in the universe
and are exceptionally attractive to
scholars of gravitational wave astronomy
by now several similar signals which
came about as a result of two small
black holes merging
have been registered by the american
observatory ligo
perhaps we will find out the names of
other champions in the list of space
giants in the near future
and now all we have left to do is just
await new
amazing discoveries
we live on a planet that is considered
young in comparison to other planetary
objects
humanity is just 2.8 million years old
while the earth is 4.5 billion years old
long before our planet appeared
thousands of such habitable worlds were
already in existence
and these objects are still somewhere in
the nearest galaxies
imagine if mankind had appeared a
billion years earlier
what technologies would we have had at
our disposal today
based on calculations by a number of
today's astrophysicists
it is an undeniable fact that there
exists a great number of similar planets
in the space
the presence of an advanced
extraterrestrial life on such planets
is simply a natural consequence why is
it then that we still haven't
received a single sign that would
indicate the presence of anyone else
around us in the space
what could be the reasons for this
absolute silence of the universe
to try to answer this question i will
tell you about one of the most
atypical and fascinating puzzles of
modern cosmology
the fermi paradox enrico fermi
is a scientist of italian descent who
emigrated to the united states
shortly before the outbreak of world war
ii
fermi worked on the design of the first
nuclear reactor
but he became well known for a phrase he
happened to drop in the cafeteria of the
los alamos laboratory
during an informal conversation in 1950
fermi together with three other
colleagues were discussing a cartoon
published in the new yorker magazine
there was a picture of aliens unloading
trash cans from flying saucers landed on
their planet
the cartoon was associated with real
disappearance of trash cans in new york
and aliens got into the picture because
of the growing interest
in extraterrestrial civilizations in
those years
when discussing this cartoon the
scientists grew to be more serious
and then firmly uttered a phrase that
was to lie in the basis
of an entire paradox
have you ever wondered where they are
according to the scientists idea
if extraterrestrial civilizations could
really exist
we would have had at least three types
of evidence
the presence of alien probes ships or
radio emissions
however despite all the ongoing research
none of these has been discovered so far
but fermi was by far not the only
scientist who thought about this
this question was raised much earlier by
the russian philosopher and inventor
constantine cialkovsky and in 1975
astrophysicist michael hart described in
detail the reasons of this paradox
fermi's question was a sensible one to
ask
just imagine any one of us can look at
the night sky right now
and see thousands of small stars
according to scientists
there are about 100 billion of them in
the milky way alone
20 of which have their own planetary
system
furthermore in each of these systems
there should be at least
one planet similar to the earth and ten
percent of these planets that can
potentially support life
may well have an intelligent
civilization
how is it possible that with such a high
probability of the existence of
extraterrestrial life
to solve this riddle the american
astronomer frank drake
developed a simple mathematical formula
in 1961
it calculated the probability of
existence of intelligent races in the
universe
here is this formula
m this is the number of civilizations
which use communication methods that we
could detect
i is the average annual rate of
emergence of stellar systems in our
galaxy
f sub p is stars that have planets
n sub a is the number of planets or
satellites that can potentially support
life
f sub l is the number of inhabited
planets that develop life
f sub i is the probability of the
emergence of intelligent life on
inhabited planets
f sub c is the fraction of civilizations
with detectable forms of communication
l is the time length of a detectable
signal
many astrophysicists have tried to
calculate each of the presented values
but to this day the drake equation has
no final solution
given the absence of any signals from
nearby stellar systems
it can be assumed that any civilization
that grows to be technologically
advanced
runs a great risk of inevitable
self-destruction
for example due to a nuclear war or
ecological collapse
thus any developed race has very little
time to be noticed
however if this does not happen any
civilization will sooner or later reach
a level of advancement that is thousands
of times
higher than ours in 1964
soviet astrophysicist nikolai kardashev
developed and published the method of
technological advancement of
civilization
called the kardashev scale using this
method
the scientists suggested an idea about
the capabilities of such developed races
these capabilities would depend on the
amount of useful energy they could make
use of
according to kardashev the first type
includes civilizations that are able to
use all the energy
available on their planet more developed
traces
can use all the energy emitted by the
main star
and the third type of race is able to
use the energy
of the according to astronomer carl
sagan so far our level is 70 percent
that of civilizations of the first type
and we will be able to reach their level
completely
in one or two centuries but even earlier
organisms that appeared in the universe
comparatively recently
could well have reached the level of
advancement of the third type of
civilization
with this kind of technologies any races
will be able to move through the space
at a speed close to the speed of light
or even faster if this really happened
we would hardly miss signs of their
presence
however the universe has never given us
a single sign of this
it is likely that the reason for this is
that we use only radio observation
methods to search for other
civilizations in the galaxy
in the entire history of the research on
extraterrestrial civilizations
not a single star has been discovered
that would demonstrate unusually intense
radio waves
this leads us to the conclusion that
we're the only civilization in our part
of the galaxy
that uses radio waves for communication
perhaps if other civilizations do exist
we don't notice them because they use
completely different types of
communication
the universe is full of things we are
unaware of and if someone does live
thousands of light years away from us
they might be able to use channels of
communication
unknown to us for example neutrinos
unfortunately this version of the
solution of the fermi paradox
is not the only one many scientists
believe
that our solitaryness in the space is an
inevitable fact
maybe we simply don't know why other
civilizations have died out
others suggest that we simply have not
yet reached the level of development
sufficient for communicating with the
universe
so it keeps silent others proponents of
the so-called zoo theory
believe that our level of development is
too low compared to extraterrestrial
races
our radio signals disappear into the
distant depths of the outer space
without a trace
and who knows maybe those who see them
simply don't understand what they mean
or maybe intelligent aliens are aware of
our attempts
but will respond only in the fullness of
time
while traveling around the universe we
have taken a look at only a few
phenomena and space
objects had we continued our journey we
would quite literally
never have seen the end of it the
variety of as yet unexplored celestial
objects and phenomena defies
human understanding and the lifetime of
every human
on earth would not be enough to even
talk about them all
but this is anything but a reason to
give up on our search
and the process of studying and
exploring the universe will continue
as long as the human race exists in its
tiny
habitable portion
[Music]
you